hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm gerry
today we're gonna talk about a movie
called ant-man and spoiler talk let's do
this so the movie starts off we take a
flashback at shield I gotta say Michael
Douglas young Michael Douglas if you can
job I thought Michael Douglas looked
that good yeah I was like wow he's
really aged well yeah I really bought it
and when they cut to the waiter I was
like oh he is this is what he really
looks like go get that is like a great
breakthrough for cinema yeah like so
many awkward flashbacks if you pay
enough for that you know technology can
be avoided what I really liked to is how
they cause for people who are not
familiar with the comics they set up
this dynamic between howard stark stark
senior and a dr. Hank Pym where you see
that yes they're both inventors but
there are two very different people yeah
which I really like seeing established
up front that way we like yeah we're
gonna get a different kind of you know
and mentor he's not gonna be like other
Marvel characters yeah here's another
high-tech suit but the movie does take
some time to you know explain why I'm
different and to give you a different
vibe around it it's nice to see John
Slattery up there I'm a madman ya know
John Slattery is [ __ ] awesome and
he's goodness Howard Stark and you know
there's some fun Easter eggs some fun
nods you know this is spoiler so you
should check out the non-spoiler review
first there's some fun Easter eggs
they're like you know everyone noticed
when you know Michael Douglas points out
that all the Avengers are probably too
busy dropping cities from skies yeah I
feel like each time I do this it gets a
little less weird to me cuz you know
it's like he threw that out as an aside
like I the Avengers brought it too busy
okay like it's starting to feel like a
universe you know where it's just these
things are commonplace now like it's
getting there and I thought that was fun
I like all their Avengers tions like the
it actually fit in this world because
the movie had a sort of self-aware sense
of humor having that self-awareness and
throwing them into the mix of the
Avengers world was actually a nice
delight prior to them me like you were
saying they could they tend to have been
distracting or sure
horned this one I thought it blended
perfectly I'm almost there with you like
a damn you I think it's gonna take me a
little time but this was the most I feel
natural tying the Avengers and am
mentioning the Avengers just alluding to
their existence like this was the one so
far that felt probably the most natural
to me without making like a supporting
character you know but even when Michael
Douglas is like this isn't the Iron Man
suit you know this isn't some he was
like down yeah I reckon it's that kind
of dialogue that I really liked it does
give an emphasis on the ant-man suit it
does show that this is a powerful suit I
feel like my phase 3 it'll be natural so
finally stopping 3 no this is the end I
was corrected this was the end of phase
two is ant-man cuz apparently from
Marvel like ant-man is really important
to all their future [ __ ] yeah he's at
man and the wasp I here or were like one
of the original founders okay yeah so
about a little late yeah yeah so when
ant-man's dropping in and then he falls
in front of the on top of the Avengers
building yeah was a nice surprise that
was a really nice surprise used to be
Stark Enterprises Stark Industries or
whatever and now it's New Avengers
building yeah exactly the cool no just
like oh I recognize that building yeah
age of Ultron yeah that was a cool
moment and I thought it was a great
Falcon cameo that they actually gave
them a fight scene it wasn't like oh
Falcons here yay now he goes away what
it makes sense that you know like he
would be pretty like you know unfriendly
downs a man from the start at least it
does show how valuable and man really is
you know like because he's taking on one
of the Avengers and he wins yeah and I
love the humor that he has about that I
became a lawyer he's talking about could
we just talk about how I just beat an
Avenger yeah as far as like having an
Avenger be a part of the movie like I
real I was really happy with Falcon what
was oh yeah I'm really like Anthony
Mackie Falcon what would not be like
someone's first choice but it worked
perfectly for the time of frame of where
the Avengers are currently at well it
also makes sense that like cuz he's you
know caps right-hand man it seems like
it makes sense that he would be keeping
things on lockdown at home you know of
course so keep the black guy at home so
racist know it's [ __ ] up say he's like
trustworthy response no man your race is
capable
you hate black people don't hate Fleck
love anthony mackie the last scene where
you're seeing a theme a key talking with
someone on a bench the woman mentions
that they have someone who crawls up
walls yeah I wish I'd caught every part
of that she's like we got a person with
this we got person is this we got a
person who crawls up walls I'm my god Oh
butter and Spidey else that was really
cool to actually hear them reference
that because because I hear spider-man
supposed to make his first appearance in
Civil War yeah because they're pretty
much setting up Civil War right now yeah
you know that's what Marvel does best is
yes you want to sign up for their next
movie now we got the awareness that yes
spider-man is definitely in the MCU and
the other thing is I love how it ended
because you see Bucky CCAP you see
Falcon they establish that there's
probably already some type of tension
between him and iron man because Falcon
was like you should we should call stark
and cap was like [ __ ] you wayne coyne
stark [ __ ] I believe he's just a busy
no he said he didn't want to call him he
said he deleted him on facebook yeah I'm
not talking to Tony write it okay he
says some some really shitty things at
my last party the last moment um Falcons
like I know someone who we can contact
or call whatever and man will return
that was cool now it's cool knowing that
a man skin' because i heard that he'll
be in civil war and i like one day a
marvel kind of gives you like these
confirmations of what's going on the
mid-credits scene with the wasp yeah
that was a nice reward I thought it was
one of the best like after movie is
finished to see ya because it's more
than just oh we got an upcoming
character it's an actual reward and a
full circle for these characters at that
moment it's like the better version of
Brody oh yeah like the better version
that was like all next time it's like
about damn time like yeah is like
getting home girl a soup what I really
appreciate about it was how it was an
impactful moment for those two
characters we yeah it's like they're
growing you know it's that he's finally
realized her capability have strength
and it's like it's time like this is
what this is yeah it's more than just a
tease that hey the wasps was gonna come
it's showing like now these characters
are they started off the part now
they're too
there you know yeah those are all the
main spoilers that I thought we should
talk about you can check out our
non-spoiler review find out more depth
about what we really thought if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out week
since Jerry on this channel and dank ass
stubs you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine periscope we're
wacky youtubers oh my god look how
charming and weird we are it's like when
the cameras rolling they're just willing
to be themselves a child like millions
of views viral video cats
right I have found you the ultimate
trailer to react to oh my god